Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History. In the year 629 AD, the Roman Emperor Heraclius restored the true cross to Jerusalem in one of the greatest ceremonies in the history of the Roman Empire. Heraclius, having defeated the Persians, now took for himself the title King of Kings. He also gave himself the Greek word basileus, which means sovereign or king. In some ways, Rome seemed to have never glittered so brightly. But Tom Holland, you could say that
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。您好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。公元629年，罗马皇帝希拉克略将真十字架归还耶路撒冷，这是罗马帝国历史上最伟大的仪式之一。希拉克略击败波斯人后，为自己取了“万王之王”的称号。他还给自己加上了希腊语词汇 basileus，意为统治者或国王。在某种程度上，罗马似乎从未如此光芒四射。但汤姆·霍兰，你可以说
this is pretty much the moment when the Roman Empire is going to end. Because last time on The Rest is History, we started talking about when the Roman Empire ended. And you could say, couldn't you, that Heraclius is the last Roman Emperor. Do you think? You could. I think it would be wrong. But you're right that the reign of Heraclius is it's a reign that is both glorious and prostratingly disastrous. It's the biggest game of two halves that you can come across in Roman history.
这几乎就是罗马帝国即将走向终结的时刻。因为在上期《历史的余烬》中，我们开始讨论罗马帝国是什么时候灭亡的。你可能会说，希拉克略难道不是最后的罗马皇帝吗？你觉得呢？你可以这么认为。我觉得这不对。但你说得对，希拉克略的统治是一个既辉煌又惨烈灾难的统治。这是罗马历史上最典型的具有截然相反两半的博弈。
Is it not a game of three halves? I mean, he loses to the Persians, he beats the Persians, and then the Arabs basically wipe the floor with him. I suppose that's true. So what we were doing for those people who didn't listen to our last episode, I mean, first of all, listen to the last episode, because what we've been doing is we've been talking about when the Roman Empire fell.
难道不是分成三个半场吗？我的意思是，他输给波斯人，他击败波斯人，然后阿拉伯人基本上把他们打得落花流水。我想这倒也是。所以，对于那些没有听我们上一期节目的听众，我的意思是，首先，去听听上一期节目，因为我们一直在讨论的是罗马帝国是什么时候灭亡的。
So we've gone through a series of dates. You may remember we talked about the Edict of Thessalonica in 380. We talked about the death of Theodosius the Great in 495. We talked about the famous date in 476, where Tom, I think, fairly comprehensively proved that the Roman Empire did not fall. And now we've moved on. So the Eastern Roman Empire, I mean, they don't call themselves the Eastern Roman Empire. They just call themselves the Roman Empire. They're still going very strong. They've lost war to the Persians. The Persians have basically hammered them. But then Heraclius has carried the fight to the Persians.
所以我们梳理了一系列日期。你可能还记得，我们讨论了380年的《塞萨洛尼基敕令》。我们讨论了495年大狄奥多西的逝世。我们讨论了476年那个著名的日期，汤姆在那个日期上，我认为相当全面地证明了罗马帝国并没有灭亡。现在我们继续。所以东罗马帝国，我的意思是，他们不把自己叫作东罗马帝国。他们只是把自己叫作罗马帝国。他们依然非常强大。他们输给波斯人了。波斯人基本上把他们狠狠打了一顿。但接着希拉克略对波斯人发动了反击。
He has this tremendous sort of triumph and stuff. Then the Arabs come famously out of the desert. Or do they? Yeah, well, exactly. Check out our episode on Muhammad. Exactly, under the banners of Islam. Or maybe they don't. Or do they? Yes, exactly. Check out our episode on Muhammad. Exactly, under the banners of Islam, or maybe they don't. Or do they?
他取得了这种巨大的胜利之类的。然后，众所周知的，阿拉伯人从沙漠中杀出。真的是这样吗？对，没错。去听听我们关于穆罕默德的节目。没错，在伊斯兰教的旗帜下。或者也许他们并没有？又或者他们真的来了？是的，没错。去听听我们关于穆罕默德的节目。没错，在伊斯兰教的旗帜下，或者也许他们并没有？又或者他们真的来了？
Yes, okay. And this is the point, Tom. Now, when I studied this as a student, this was sort of the point where all the textbooks said, you know, something changes here. This really is a punctuation point, because there has been a series of kind of terrible climactic events in the 6th century. There has been a general economic crash. There's been a plague, an absolutely devastating pandemic.
是的，好吧。这就是关键所在，汤姆。当年我作为学生学到这里时，所有的教科书基本上都说，你知道的，这里发生了一些变化。这确实是一个标点符号式的转折点，因为在6世纪发生了一系列可怕的、决定性的事件。发生了一场全面的经济崩盘。发生了一场瘟疫，一场绝对毁灭性的全球大流行。
On top of this, you have the rise of Islam. And at the end of all this sort of swirl, the Roman Empire is very, very very different it's a different kind of society different civilization the greek has taken prominence over latin christianity has driven out the kind of roman civil religion of the past so so is that all true do you think or do you think that's overstated no i think it's a it's an absolute rupture point. Oh, I thought you were going to argue the opposite. No, no, no, no. I've set that up very badly. No, not at all. I agree.
除此之外，你还有伊斯兰教的兴起。在这所有这一切的动荡之后，罗马帝国变得非常、非常不同，它成了一种不同类型的社会、不同的文明，希腊语取代拉丁语占据了主导地位，基督教驱逐了过去那种罗马公民宗教……那么，这一切都是真的吗？你觉得是这样，还是你觉得这种说法被夸大了？不，我认为这是一个绝对的决裂点。哦，我还以为你会反驳呢。不，不，不，不。我刚才把这话说得太糟糕了。不，完全不是。我同意。
I mean, so historians will often describe the Roman Empire up until the coming of the Arabs as East Rome, as the East Roman Empire. And then it becomes, it conventionally comes to be called Byzantium. And, you know, they're artificial. It's not what the Romans themselves would have called themselves. But I think it does convey the degree to which this is an absolutely radical break, because the implications of the Arab conquests is that Byzantium, Constantinople, loses its wealthiest provinces. So it loses Syria. It loses Egypt. It will come to lose North Africa. And at the same time, it is also being battered by invasions through the Balkans. So it's absolutely staggering, really, that Constantinople doesn't fall, that the empire kind of staggers on. So large numbers of immigrants from the Balkans settle right the way down into the Peloponnese in Greece.
我的意思是，历史学家通常会将阿拉伯人到来之前的罗马帝国描述为东罗马，即东罗马帝国。然后它变成了，按惯例开始被称为拜占庭。而且，你知道的，这些都是人为的划分。这不是罗马人自己对自己的称呼。但我认为它确实传达了这是一种绝对根本性的断裂的程度，因为阿拉伯人征服的后果是拜占庭、君士坦丁堡失去了最富裕的行省。所以它失去了叙利亚。它失去了埃及。它后来还将失去北非。与此同时，它还不断遭到通过巴尔干半岛的入侵的打击。所以，君士坦丁堡没有沦陷，帝国勉强支撑下去，这真的是极其令人震惊的。因此，来自巴尔干半岛的大量移民一直向南定居到希腊的伯罗奔尼撒半岛。
The frontier with what becomes Islam, the Taurus Mountains in what's now southeastern Turkey. I mean, very, very bloody. Constantinople itself just about survives two very, very menacing sieges by the Arabs, which is one of the kind of inspirations for Tolkien's portrayal of the siege of Minas Tirith. That's the kind of the measure of how close Constantinople comes to falling. The emperor's holdings in Italy and Sicily come under constant threat, kind of fragment and large chunks of it dissolve away. So essentially, it's very much on its uppers. Yeah. And it's able to claw its way back until in the 10th and 11th century. It's it's successfully-established itself absolutely as a kind of major, major regional power. And Constantinople by that point has become,
与后来成为伊斯兰世界的边界，即现在土耳其东南部的托罗斯山脉。我的意思是，非常、非常血腥。君士坦丁堡本身勉强挺过了阿拉伯人两次非常、非常具有威胁性的围城，这也是托尔金对米那斯提力斯围城描绘的灵感来源之一。这就是君士坦丁堡险些沦陷的程度的写照。皇帝在意大利和西红柿（应为西西里）的领地受到不断威胁，逐渐碎片化，大部分都瓦解消失了。所以本质上，它已经处于强弩之末。是的。而且它能够一路反弹，直到在10世纪和11世纪。它成功地确立了自己作为绝对的主要、主要地区强国的地位。到那个时候，君士坦丁堡已经变得
you know, very, very wealthy again. And it's absolutely a Roman empire. They still see themselves as the heirs of the line of the Roman emperors. The measure of that is that with Charlemagne, we'll probably come to Charlemagne, people in the Latin West claim that the Western empire has been restored. And the Romans in the East, the Byzantines are furious about this, very, very upset about it. So the name of Romans still matters to them very, very deeply. What has changed however is that you know as you said a sense of the kind of organic continuity has gone so that when people in the 10th 11th 12th century in byzantium in constantinople look at the um the statues of emperors set up in the fourth century or the
你知道的，再次变得非常、非常富有。而且它绝对是一个罗马帝国。他们仍然视自己为罗马皇帝血统的继承者。这方面的证明是，随着查理曼的出现——我们可能会谈到查理曼——拉丁西方的民众声称西方帝国已经恢复。而东方的罗马人，即拜占庭人对此感到愤怒，对此感到非常、非常心烦意乱。因此，罗马人的名号对他们来说仍然非常、非常重要。然而，改变的是，正如你所说的那种有机延续感已经消失了，所以当10世纪、11世纪、12世纪拜占庭、君士坦丁堡的人们看到4世纪设立的皇帝雕像时，或者
fifth century or the sixth century or freezes they don't know what they are they can't remember them often they assume that these are statues of demons or portrayals of the world that is to come um but what they still very much have is and this is also true of people in the West, is that Rome's empire is eternal. Their empire is eternal, that it has a key role to play in the apocalyptic drama that Christians believe is destined to happen. But they think it's eternal, though, Tom, do they? Because it's Christian rather than because it's Roman. That's a slight difference, isn't it? Now I know that in the previous episode,
5世纪或6世纪的雕像或浮雕，他们不知道那是什么，他们记不得了，通常他们认为这些是恶魔的雕像或对未来世界的描绘，嗯……但他们仍然非常拥有的，西方人也是如此，那就是罗马的帝国是永恒的。他们的帝国是永恒的，它在基督徒认为注定要发生的末日戏剧中扮演着关键角色。但汤姆，他们真的认为它是永恒的吗？因为它是基督教的，而不是因为它是罗马的？这是一个细微的差别，不是吗？现在我知道在上一集里，
we talked about how some theologians and obviously emperors and so on had, had, had kind of entangled the two, the idea that Rome was the essential vehicle for Christianity. But am I right in thinking in this sort of later medieval period, people who think that Rome is eternal, think it's eternal purely because it's Christian rather than, I mean, they don't care about Cato and Octavian. No, absolutely. They're not interested. They're not interested in Augustus or Trajan. They are interested, you know, the scholars are interested in Constantine or Theodosius or Justinian. Most
我们讨论了某些神学家、当然还有皇帝等等，如何将这两者纠缠在一起，即罗马是基督教的基本载体这一观点。但是，我这样想对吗：在后来的这个中世纪时期，那些认为罗马是永恒的人，认为它是永恒纯粹是因为它是基督教的，而不是——我的意思是，他们根本不在乎加图和屋大维？不，绝对不在乎。他们不感兴趣。他们对奥古斯都或图拉真不感兴趣。他们感兴趣的是，你知道的，学者们对君士坦丁堡（应为君士坦丁）、狄奥多西或查士丁尼感兴趣。大多数
people don't even remember them. So these are the people for whom these statues are kind of potentially necromantic figures. But there are prophecies in which it is the dignity of Rome that it will essentially, when everything is going tits up, you have this prophecy that supposedly had been written by a guy called Methodius three centuries previously. It was a saint and a martyr, supposedly, in which he says that at the end of days, the world will be invaded by Gog and Magog, who are biblical kind of tribesmen who lurk on the end of the edges of the world and this is obviously a representation of the arabs of the the balkan tribes um the sense that you know the civilized world is being overwhelmed by vast waves of barbarians from the outer limits of the world so there's this sense that at the end of the day gog and magog will invade. The last Roman emperor will fight them and will hurl them back and will wall them up behind great gates of brass. And having done that, the last Roman emperor will then travel to Jerusalem. He'll arrive in Jerusalem. And when he does, suddenly seated on Temple Mount, so where the Jewish temple had stood in Jerusalem, Antichrist will appear enthroned in dark and terrible splendor like Sauron.
人甚至不记得他们。所以对这些人来说，这些雕像可能具有通灵性质的人物。但有一些预言，其中罗马的尊严在于，当一切都搞砸时，你会有这样一个预言，据说是由一个叫美多丢斯的人在三个世纪前写的。据说他是一位圣人和殉道者，他在书中说，在末日之时，世界将被歌革和玛各入侵，他们是潜伏在世界边缘的圣经中的某种部落，这显然是阿拉伯人、巴尔干部落的写照，这种（感觉）你知道的，文明世界正被来自世界边缘的大批野蛮人浪潮所淹没……所以有这样一种感觉，即在末日之时，歌革和玛各将会入侵。最后一个罗马皇帝将与他们战斗，将他们击退，并把他们筑墙围在巨大的黄铜大门后面。做完这些后，最后一个罗马皇帝将前往耶路撒冷。他将抵达耶路撒冷。当他到达时，突然端坐在圣殿山上——也就是耶路撒冷的犹太圣殿曾矗立的地方——敌基督将像索伦一样，带着黑暗而可怕的光辉登基出现。
And the last Roman emperor will then climb the hill of Golgotha. And when he does so, the cross on which Christ had been crucified will appear. The Roman emperor will kneel before it, will die. The cross will be raised up to heaven and the darkness of antichrist will cover the whole world but this will presage the last coming and it's a kind of fantastical image of the future that has an unbelievable potency both in in in constantinople and in the lands of the latin west because it it it kind of restores to the roman empire what augustine had taken away from it saint augustine who we talked about in the Roman Empire what Augustine had taken away from it.
然后最后一个罗马皇帝将登上各各他山。当他这么做时，基督被钉死其上的十字架将出现。罗马皇帝将在其面前跪下，然后死去。十字架将被高举到天堂，敌基督的黑暗将笼罩整个世界，但这将预示着第二次降临，这是一种对未来的奇幻想象，在君士坦丁堡和拉丁西方的大地上具有难以置信的威力，因为它将奥古斯都（应为奥古斯丁）从罗马帝国夺走的东西归还给了罗马帝国，圣奥古斯丁——我们在第一集里谈到过——在罗马帝国中，奥古斯丁从它那里夺走了什么。
St. Augustine, who we talked about in the first episode. Augustine's take is that Roman Empire is nothing special. It doesn't matter. It can crumble away. Unimportant. What matters is that the church endures. But this kind of, this myth of the last Roman Emperor, it serves as a kind of lightning rod
圣奥古斯丁，我们在第一集里谈到过。奥古斯丁的看法是，罗马帝国没什么特别的。这不重要。它大可以土崩瓦解。无足轻重。重要的是教会长存。但这种，末代罗马皇帝的神话，它充当了一种避雷针，
for those who want to believe that the Roman Empire must survive because it has this kind of eternal destiny. Okay. That's weird and fascinating. It is weird. But I just want to rewind for a second to the 7th century. So to that punctuation point we talked about. So I suppose the conventional date, we didn't mention it, which was my folly,
为了那些想要相信罗马帝国必须生存下去的人，因为它拥有这种永恒的命运。好吧。这既诡异又迷人。确实很诡异。但我只想把时间倒回几秒钟，回到7世纪。也就是我们讨论过的那个标点符号般的转折点。所以我想传统日期——我们没有提到它，这是我的愚蠢——
is August 636, which is the Battle of the Yarmouk, which is when the Byzantine army lose to the Arabs, don't they? I mean, it's this absolutely landmark kind of defeat. Now, at that point in the 7th century, Tom, in the West, in the former Roman provinces, nobody at that stage thinks they're still living in the Roman Empire, do they? I mean, they're very conscious that they are living in kingdoms. Well, the Pope does, for instance.
是636年8月，即雅穆克战役，拜占庭军队正是在那里输给了阿拉伯人，不是吗？我的意思是，这是一场绝对具有里程碑意义的失败。那么，在7世纪的那个时候，汤姆，在西方，在前罗马行省，当时没有人认为他们还生活在罗马帝国里，对吧？我的意思是，他们非常清楚自己生活在各个王国里。嗯，教皇是这样的，比如说。
So the Pope in Rome is a subject of the emperor in Constantinople. But not in Gaul. Ravenna is in Spain or certainly not in Britain. So it's all gone there. But obviously the idea of Roman-ness and of the Roman Empire continuing, that does endure. And it obviously endures in Constantinople. But as you said, it's different. So for example, there's a historian who's published a couple of books in the last few years called Anthony Kaldelis, I think his name is, or Kaldelis. And he argues
所以罗马的教皇是君士坦丁堡皇帝的臣民。但高卢不是。拉文纳在西班牙，或者肯定不在不列颠。所以那边一切都烟消云散了。但显然，“罗马性”以及罗马帝国延续的观念确实存在。而且它显然在君士坦丁堡得以延续。但正如你所说，它不同了。所以，例如，有一位历史学家在过去几年里出版了几本书，我想他的名字叫安东尼·卡尔德利斯，或者卡尔德利斯。他认为
that there was a kind of Roman nation state, that a Byzantine empire is basically a Roman nation state. Everyone thinks of themselves as Roman. You said they call themselves Romoi. He says they're not a sort of woolly multicultural empire. They are Roman and they're a nation. That's how we should think of them. Do you buy that argument? I think that one of the ways that Byzantium is able to survive is by forging a very coherent sense of a kind of embattled Christian people who have a key role to play in the great supernatural drama of the future,
存在着某种罗马民族国家，拜占庭帝国基本上就是一个罗马民族国家。每个人都认为自己是罗马人。你刚才说他们自称 Romoi。他说他们不是那种模糊不清的多元文化帝国。他们是罗马人，他们是一个民族。这才是我们应该看待他们的方式。你赞同这个观点吗？我认为拜占庭能够生存下去的方式之一，是塑造了一种非常具有凝聚力的、处于困境中的基督教民族意识，他们在未来的伟大超自然戏剧中扮演着关键角色，
and whose city is the capital of the world. And if you want to call that a nation state, I mean, I think nation state would be an anachronistic way of framing it. But absolutely, it's that sense of kind of centralized identity that is key to it. The confusion is that people in the West call them Greeks because they speak Greek. And if you want to call it a nation state, this is the model for Greece as it will emerge in the 19th century, the independent nation state of Greece. But of course, to them, they remain Romans. And they use the word, even though they don't speak Latin.
并且他们的城市是世界的首都。如果你想称之为民族国家——我的意思是，我认为民族国家将是一个时代的错置的框架方式。但绝对地，那种中心化的身份认同感才是关键所在。混乱之处在于，西方人因为他们说希腊语而称他们为希腊人。如果你想称之为民族国家，这就是19世纪将要出现的希腊的模式，即希腊独立的民族国家。但当然，对他们而言，他们依然是罗马人。他们使用这个词，即使他们不说拉丁语。
Yeah. And they don't see any contradiction between the fact that they don't speak Latin. They see none of that. And they don't live in Rome. No, no, none at all. None at all. And this sense is influential, not just on the Byzantines themselves, but on their neighbours. So I mentioned how they kind of claw their way back. They are absolutely a regional superpower in the 10th and 11th centuries then you get and we talked about this in the 12 days of christmas the battle of manzikert and the civil war that follows that
是的。而且他们认为自己不说拉丁语这事实之间没有任何矛盾。他们完全不觉得有矛盾。而且他们不住在罗马。不，不，完全没有。完全没有。这种意识不仅对拜占庭人本身产生影响，也对他们的邻居产生影响。所以我提到过他们是如何艰难反弹的。他们在10世纪和11世纪绝对是一个地区超级大国，然后你就会遇到——我们在圣诞节12天里讨论过这个——曼齐克尔特战役以及随之而来的内战，
and that's disastrous because the the kind of the great recruiting ground for byzantine armies was asia minor um anatolia what's now. And it's now called Turkey because it's the Turks who win at the Battle of Manzikert. And they start kind of infiltrating, taking advantage of the civil wars that follow Manzikert and increasingly kind of occupying it. And you get this Islamic sultanate parking itself in the middle of what had been this Christian heartland. And it calls itself the Sultanate of Rome. So as in Rome. Yeah, the Sultanate of Rome. But they don't call themselves Romans. No, they don't. But they look to Constantinople as being a worthy capital of the world. And
那是灾难性的，因为拜占庭军队的大招募地是小亚细亚，安纳托利亚，也就是现在的地方。现在它被称为土耳其，因为在曼齐克尔特战役中获胜的是土耳其人。他们开始某种程度的渗透，利用曼齐克尔特之后的内战，并越来越多地占领它。你看到这个伊斯兰苏丹国把自己安插在曾是基督教腹地的中心。它自称为罗马苏丹国。也就是罗马。是的，罗马苏丹国。但他们不自称罗马人。不，他们不自称。但他们将君士坦丁堡视为一个当之无愧的世界首都。而且
one of the things that is really interesting is that for the Muslims, they look back to sayings that are attributed to the prophet, which derived from an age when Constantinople was the one great city that defied the caliphate, defied the world of Islam. And so for the Muslims as well, Constantinople has a key role to play in this kind of apocalyptic imagery. So for them, there are sayings of Muhammad that says, Constantinople will be the first to fall, then Rome will fall. But the Romans are a people who will be fighting you till the end of days. And these are prophecies that kind of motivate, you know, in due course, you have Manzikert, you have the Turks starting to move into Anatolia. Then in 1204, you have this calamitous intervention by the Crusaders when they capture Constantinople. on the Byzantine Empire as an absolute shadow of itself. And you start to get the Ottomans, who are, again, a Turkic people,
有一件非常有趣的事情是，对于穆斯林来说，他们回溯到归属于先知的言论，这些言论源于一个时代，当时君士坦丁堡是唯一一个公开反抗哈里发国、反抗伊斯兰世界的伟大城市。因此，对于穆斯林来说，君士坦丁堡在这种末世论的意象中也扮演着关键角色。对他们而言，有穆罕默德的言论说，君士坦丁堡将第一个沦陷，然后罗马将沦陷。但罗马人是一个将与你们战斗到世界末日的民族。这些预言推动了——理所当然地，你有了曼齐克尔特，土耳其人开始迁入安纳托利亚。然后在1204年，十字军攻占君士坦丁堡，发生了这场灾难性的干预。拜占庭帝国沦为自身的绝对阴影。你开始看到奥斯曼人，他们同样是一个突厥民族，
who managed to cross the straits from Asia into Europe. And so increasingly, Constantinople comes to be surrounded. And they are eyeing Constantinople up as a worthy capital of what will become their sultanate in the long run, their caliphate. And when in 1453, which is the traditional date for the end of the Byzantine Empire, and therefore for the end of the Roman Empire, when that happens, Mehmed II, the Ottoman sultan who captures Constantinople, his mother is Greek.
他们设法穿过从亚洲到欧洲的海峡。因此，君士坦丁堡越来越多地被包围。他们将君士坦丁堡视作他们长远来看将成为的苏丹国、哈里发国的当之无愧的首都。而在1453年——这是拜占庭帝国结束的传统日期，因而也是罗马帝国结束的传统日期——当这一切发生时，征服君士坦丁堡的奥斯曼苏丹穆罕默德二世，他的母亲是希腊人。
He is aware of these kind of traditions. And in the great portrait that is made of him by bellini there are three crowns in the high corner and these symbolize the three continents that that memet ii uh is ruling and he does have a consciousness of himself as the heir of the roman empire but the heir of the roman empire the christian roman empire no so yeah so all gone all gone yeah so in that sense 1453 again is a very you know i mean that is the terminus i don't think it's the complete terminus before we get back to 1453 i just want to dig into a previous date you mentioned which is 1204 because 1204 occurred to me is quite a nice contender for this crown because that's the point at which isn't it's absolutely arguably one of the single most disgraceful episodes in european history the crusaders
他了解这些传统。在贝利尼为他画的著名肖像画中，高处角落里有三个皇冠，这些象征着穆罕默德二世统治的三个大洲，他确实有一种自己是罗马帝国继承人的意识，但作为基督教罗马帝国的继承人？不。所以，是的，一切都烟消云散了，一切都烟消云散了，是的。所以在某种意义上，1453年再次是一个非常——我的意思是，那是终点站。我不认为这是彻底的终点站。在我们回到1453年之前，我只想深入探讨你提到的一个之前的日期，那就是1204年，因为我突然觉得1204年是这个桂冠的一个相当不错的竞争者，因为那是——难道不是吗——欧洲历史上绝对可以说最不光彩的事件之一，十字军
basically you know completely breaking their promises and stuff and sacking constantinople kicking out now that's a huge punctuation point because that's the i mean the romans have had two capitals in their long history in rome and in constantinople they've now lost both of them because the crusaders take charge in constantinople um the the remaining romans as they are called as they would have called themselves they basically go off to to trebizond greece to they sort of scattered and they um but then they get they do get it back but the the after they get constantinople back the game is kind of up it's a spectral thing yeah it's their sort of ghostly presence so do you think 1204 would be a good uh is a good no because because as you said they do manage to claw it
基本上，你知道的，完全背弃了承诺等等，洗劫了君士坦丁堡，把人赶走……现在，这是一个巨大的标点符号般的转折点，因为那是——我的意思是，罗马人在漫长的历史中有过两个首都，在罗马和君士坦丁堡。他们现在两个都失去了，因为十字军接管了君士坦丁堡，嗯……剩下的罗马人——正如他们被称为的那样，正如他们自己会称呼的那样——他们基本上去了特拉布宗、希腊，他们四散开来，他们……但随后他们确实夺回了它，但在他们夺回君士坦丁堡之后，大局基本上已定，它成了一种幽灵般的存在。是的，这是他们某种幽灵般的存留。所以你认为1204年会是一个好——是一个好……不，因为正如你所说，他们确实设法夺回了它，
back uh and so there is you know and they you know there are that there is the continuous line of emperors is preserved there's there's a fracture point. There's not a break. And so when they recapture Constantinople from the Latin occupiers, they're simply restoring a capital to an empire that they felt had continued. I think that 1453, when Constantinople falls, is the obvious terminus. But it's not conclusively the terminus because there is one last holdout, which is Trebizond,
因此——并且——你知道的，皇帝的连续血统得以保存。这是一个断裂点。不是彻底的破裂。因此，当他们从拉丁占领者手中夺回君士坦丁堡时，他们只是在恢复一个他们觉得仍在延续的帝国的首都。我认为1453年，当君士坦丁堡沦陷时，是显而易见的终点站。但这并不是决定性的终点站，因为还有一个最后的据点，那就是特拉布宗，
which is on the Black Sea, which falls in 1461. And I think if you wanted to be strictly accurate, that would be the date that you would give. So just as you, it's not when Romulus Augustulus gets deposed that you have the last emperor in the East, it's when Julius Nepos in 480 gets deposed. So likewise, 1453, although it's the obvious, obvious date, it's actually 1461. But the fall of Trebizond is obviously that much less dramatic. And I think
位于黑海，于1461年陷落。我认为如果你想做到严格准确，那将是你给出的日期。就像你所知，东方最后一个皇帝并不是在罗穆卢斯·奥古斯都卢斯被废黜时出现的，而是在480年尤利乌斯·尼波斯被废黜时。同样，1453年虽然是显而易见的日期，但实际上是1461年。但特拉布宗的陷落显然戏剧性要小得多。我想
that that is then the Roman Empire is dead. Well, I was going to say, in the world's imagination, Tom, does 1453 loom that large at the time? Do people sort of say, gosh, the Roman Empire has come to an end? Completely. Yes, it's a terrible, terrible shock. A terrible shock. It reverberates throughout Christendom. One of the measures of that is that a romance is written, Tiron Leblanc, I think in Catalonia, a couple of years, a few years after the fall of Constantinople, in which the shock is so great that they recapture it. And it's a kind of counterfactual in which the Roman Empire carries on. And I think it's, yes, I think it's an absolutely devastating moment. But the Roman Empire that people think has fallen,
那之后，罗马帝国才算真正死亡。嗯，我是想说，在世界的想象中，汤姆，1453年在当时有那么大的分量吗？人们会说，天哪，罗马帝国结束了吗？完全有。是的，这是一个非常、非常震撼的打击。一个可怕的打击。它在整个基督教世界引起共鸣。这方面的证明之一是，在君士坦丁堡沦陷后几年内，在加泰罗尼亚编写了一部传奇故事《蒂朗白骑士》（Tirant lo Blanc），其中的震撼如此之大，以至于他们重新夺回了君士坦丁堡。这是一个反事实的设想，罗马帝国在其中延续了下去。我想是的，我认为这是一个绝对毁灭性的时刻。但人们认为已经灭亡的罗马帝国，
so we're in the age of kind of very much still the age of Christendom, the empire that they're mourning, they're mourning the empire of Constantine, aren't they, rather than the empire of Augustus and Hadrian and Claudius? Yeah, they're mourning the great bulwark, the great Christian bulwark against Islam. It's not that they don't think that what has fallen is the empire of, that was set up by Augustus. Or do they?
所以我们仍然处于基督教世界的时代，他们哀悼的帝国，他们哀悼的是君士坦丁堡的帝国，对吧，而不是屋大维、哈德良和克劳狄乌斯的帝国？是的，他们在哀悼伟大的堡垒，反对伊斯兰教的伟大基督教堡垒。并不是说他们不认为沦陷的是由奥古斯都建立的帝国。还是说他们真的这么认为？
I think some scholars do. Yeah. Some scholars do. But I think it's, the fame of Constantinople is very, very great. And I think there is a sense that something, you know,
我想有些学者是这么认为的。是的。有些学者是。但我认为，君士坦丁堡的名声非常、非常大。而且我认为有一种感觉，即某种，
very ancient has, has, has gone. Yeah. Has gone or has it gone, Tom? Because don't you have a whole theory about undead Rome and zombies, which I've been greatly looking forward to,
非常古老的东西，已经，已经，已经消失了。嗯……是真的消失了，还是没有消失，汤姆？因为你难道没有一整套关于“不死罗马”和“僵尸”的理论吗？我一直非常期待这个，
the sort of walking dead of Roman history. Well, I mean, because the truth is that there have been many attempts to dig the corpse of the Roman Empire out of its grave and to reanimate it. Yeah, you haven't talked about the Roman Empire at all. Yeah. So I think we should have a look at those attempts in the second half. Excellent.
罗马历史上的某种“行尸走肉”。好吧，我的意思是，因为事实是，曾有过许多次尝试将罗马帝国的尸体从坟墓中挖出来并让它重新复活。是的，你根本没谈到罗马帝国。是的。所以我觉得我们应该在下半场看一看这些尝试。太棒了。
And maybe decide which is the most convincing. I look forward to it. Okay, see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
也许还能决定哪一个最具说服力。我很期待。好的，中场休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom Holland has spent the break vigorously digging up the corpse, the rotting corpse of the Roman Empire, and he's about to present us with a series of zombie figures. So we did promise that we would talk a little bit about the Holy Roman Empire, Tom, and that's the Empire of Charlemagne, who you mentioned earlier, but we never really got into. So tell us a little bit about this and, well, tell us about why this is or isn't the
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。汤姆·霍兰在休息期间一直在大力挖掘罗马帝国的尸体，腐烂的尸体，他即将向我们展示一系列僵尸般的人物。所以我们确实承诺过我们会稍微谈谈神圣罗马帝国，汤姆，那是查理曼的帝国，你之前提到过，但我们从未真正深入探讨过。所以给我们讲讲这个，以及——嗯，告诉我们为什么这是或不是
Roman Empire. Right. So when the Roman Empire in the West falls, left hanging is the possibility that perhaps it might be revived. And the Byzantine emperors themselves, as we said in the first episode, you know, they do pander to the kind of various barbarian warlords and kings who've taken over chunks of former Roman provinces by kind of handing them out titles and imperial robes and all that kind of stuff. So it is hanging in the air. We did an episode on this, actually the first of our 12 days of Christmas, wasn't it? So if you're interested in more on this, do check that out. But very briefly, Charlemagne, Frankish king,
罗马帝国。好的。因此，当西罗马帝国灭亡时，留下的悬念是它或许可能会复兴的可能性。正如我们在第一集里所说的那样，拜占庭皇帝自己，你知道的，他们确实迎合了那些接管了前罗马行省大片土地的各种蛮族军阀和国王，向他们分发头衔、御袍以及所有诸如此类的东西。所以这种可能性一直悬在空中。我们其实做过一期关于这个的节目，就是我们圣诞节12天的第一天，不是吗？所以如果你对这方面感兴趣，一定要去听听。但简而言之，查理曼，法兰克国王，
becomes sufficiently powerful that he can legitimately, as he sees it, be crowned as emperor actually in Rome. So the first emperor to be crowned in Rome since Julius Nepos, the previous emperor of the West. And one of the reasons why this happens, or in fact, the key reason why this happens, is that the pope in Rome, so the most significant figure in the Latin church, had previously looked to Constantinople for protection. And the emperor in Byzantium is no longer able to do that. So the pope is looking to essentially to kind of big up Charlemagne so that he'll be in a position to do what the pope
变得足够强大，以至于他可以理所当然地——正如他所认为的那样——实际上在罗马加冕为皇帝。因此，他是自西方的上一位皇帝尤利乌斯·尼波斯以来，第一位在罗马加冕的皇帝。发生这种情况的原因之一，或者事实上这背后的关键原因，是罗马的教皇——也就是拉丁教会中最重要的人物——以前一直指望君士坦丁堡来获得保护。而拜占庭的皇帝已经无力做到这一点了。所以教皇基本上是在寻找——为了抬高查理曼，以便他能够处于能够做教皇
thinks emperors should do, which is to look after popes. This becomes one of the kind of great dynamos of medieval history, what the relationship of the emperor and the pope should do, which is to look after popes. Right. You know, this becomes one of the kind of great dynamos of medieval history, what the relationship of the emperor and the pope should be, who should have primacy, is the argument that the emperor has a key role in the history of the apocalypse, you know, the last Roman emperor, that kind of figure, you know, does that, in other words, is the figure of the emperor the key one? Or do you go with the kind of more, the approach argued by Augustine that the Roman Empire in itself and of itself is not particularly significant, what matters is the church, and that therefore the empire should be subordinate to the church. And there's heated debate. Let's put it that way. Let's not get into it. I mean, we'll never get out of that rubber hole if we go down there tom i know once you get into canossa there's no there's no turning from that but essentially the holy roman empire i mean people the voltaire's joke is that it's neither holy nor roman nor nor an empire uh it is actually holy i mean right if it weren't holy it
认为皇帝应该做的事情的地位，那就是照顾教皇。这成为了中世纪历史的伟大动力之一，即皇帝与教皇的关系应该如何，谁应该拥有至高无上的地位，争论的焦点是皇帝在末日历史中扮演关键角色，你知道的，末代罗马皇帝，那种人物，你知道的，是否做到这一点，换句话说，皇帝的人物形象是关键吗？还是你赞同奥古斯都（应为奥古斯丁）提出的那种更倾向于的观点，即罗马帝国本身并不是特别重要，重要的是教会，因此帝国应该从属于教会。这里有激烈的争论。我们这么说吧。我们不要陷入其中。我的意思是，如果我们顺着那个兔洞往下走，我们就永远出不去了，汤姆。我知道一旦你卷入卡诺萨之行，就再也没有回头路了。但本质上，神圣罗马帝国——伏尔泰的笑话是它既不神圣、也不罗马、也不是一个帝国——它实际上是神圣的，对吧，如果它不神圣的话，
wouldn't you know that it has a sacral quality don't it oh very nice sacral quality and i suppose you're now going to tell me that it is also Roman, because the idea of Roman-ness matters so much to it, right? Yes, exactly. I mean, I know there are Germans who rule it, but I suppose you would say, going back to the first podcast we did on this topic, that the Roman Empire was often ruled by, you know, as you said, barbarians. Novak Djokovic kind of types.
你不会知道它具有某种神圣的品质，对吧？哦，非常好，具有神圣的品质。我想你现在要告诉我它也是罗马的，因为罗马性的观念对它而言非常重要，对吧？是的，完全如此。我的意思是，我知道统治它的是德国人，但我想你会说，回到我们关于这个主题的第一期播客，罗马帝国经常由——正如你所说——蛮族统治。Novak Djokovic（诺瓦克·德约科维奇，此处疑为主播口误或幽默比喻）那种类型。
Yeah. And it is, but it's not an empire, the Holy Roman Empire. Well, it's an imperium. I mean, it claims power. So I think in that sense, it is an empire. Yeah, fair enough. All right. So Voltaire has been comprehensively, you know,
是的。它是，但它不是一个帝国，神圣罗马帝国。嗯，它是一个 imperium。我的意思是，它声称拥有权力。所以我觉得在这个意义上，它是一个帝国。嗯，有道理。好吧。所以伏尔泰已经被彻底地，
has been beclowned. Well, let's say it's Roman-ish. Okay, very good. And empire-ish, I suppose. It's Roman-ish, empire-ish, and holy-ish. And you're going to,. It's Roman-ish, empire-ish, and holy-ish. But it's not the only kind of imperium that thinks itself a successor to the Romans. I mean, the Ottomans, in a sense, think of themselves as successors. I think less so.
被当众打脸了。好吧，我们姑且说它“很罗马”吧。好的，非常好。我想它也“很帝国”。它很罗马、很帝国、也很神圣。你打算……它很罗马、很帝国、也很神圣。但它并不是唯一一个认为自己是罗马继承者的 imperium。我的意思是，奥斯曼人在某种程度上也认为自己是继承者。我认为没那么强。
Well, they're surrounded by the monuments. Yes, but they change them, don't they? So they have Hagia Sophia, the great cathedral built by Justinian, but they convert it into a mosque. Right, but they don't tear it down. No, they don't. They convert it. Yeah. And the cathedrals of Roman Christian Constantinople are monuments that bear witness to the triumph of Islam.
好吧，他们被那些古迹包围着。是的，但他们改变了它们，不是吗？所以他们拥有圣索菲亚大教堂，由查士丁尼建造的大教堂，但他们把它改成了清真寺。没错，但他们没有把它拆毁。不，他们没有。他们把它改建了。是的。君士坦丁堡的罗马基督教大教堂是见证伊斯兰教胜利的古迹。
Yes. So it's, you know, Rome is conquered. Yeah. That's the point. It's subdued. So in that sense, it's not Roman. And the sense of being the heir of the Roman Empire fades pretty quickly in Constantinople. But there is another Eastern power where the sense of continuity with
是的。所以，你知道的，罗马被征服了。是的。这就是重点。它被制服了。所以在那种意义上，它不是罗马。而且那种作为罗马帝国继承人的意识在君士坦丁堡迅速消退。但还有另一个东方强权，那里与
um with rome and particularly with the second rome is very very strong and um it's a part of the world that we've been talking about quite a lot recently and that of course is muscovy right is what becomes russia so that comes i mean you're right we have done quite a lot on this recently so for those of you who don't know the vik sailed down the Volga and the Dnieper, these rivers in the 8th, 9th, 10th centuries. They basically kind of co-found Kiev. Their society ends up coming into the orbit of Constantinople. They adopt Byzantine Orthodox Christianity, don't they?
嗯……罗马的延续感，尤其是与第二罗马的延续感非常、非常强烈，嗯……这是我们最近一直在谈论的世界的一部分，当然那就是莫斯科，对吧，也就是后来的俄罗斯。所以这——我的意思是，你说得对，我们最近在这个上面确实做了很多内容。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，维京人顺着伏尔加河和第聂伯河航行，这些河流在8世纪、9世纪、10世纪。他们基本上共同创立了基辅。他们的社会最终进入了君士坦丁堡的轨道。他们接受了拜占庭东正教 Christianity，不是吗？
They do. And at what point, Tom, do they, do these, well, who is it that first talks about a third Rome? It's not, is it, because Kiev isn't the third Rome, is it? It seems to be a Russian monk called Philotius, who writes in 1510 and he's writing to um a prince called vasily and vasily is the son of ivan the third of moscovy but crucially is also the son of the niece of the last emperor of constantinople constantine palaiologos who died fighting the turks so so it's not just an ideological link. There's a kind of blood link as well.
他们确实如此。汤姆，在什么时间点，他们——这些——嗯，是谁最早谈论“第三罗马”的？不是，对吧，因为基辅不是第三罗马，对吧？似乎是一个名叫菲洛修斯的俄罗斯僧侣，他在1510年写道，他写信给
There is absolutely a blood link. And, of course, Vasily is a Russification of Basileus, who, as you mentioned, the Greek word for emperor. So this monk, Volotius, writes to Vasily, Basileus, the son of the niece of the last emperor of Constantinople. And he says that two Rome's have fallen. The third Rome though stands, nor will there ever be a fourth. And he says that no one shall ever replace your Christian Sodom. He says this to to vasily um and it's that idea that uh you have a kind of um translatio imperi it's called the movement of the capital of the empire so from
一个叫瓦西里的亲王，瓦西里是莫斯科的伊凡三世的儿子，但至关重要的是，他也是君士坦丁堡最后一位皇帝君士坦丁·帕莱奥洛戈斯（在与土耳其人的战斗中牺牲）的侄女的儿子。所以这不仅仅是一种意识形态上的联系。还有一种血缘上的联系。绝对有一种血缘上的联系。当然，瓦西里（Vasily）是巴西琉斯（Basileus）的俄罗斯化称呼，正如你所提到的，这是皇帝的希腊语词汇。所以这个僧侣，沃洛修斯（应为菲洛修斯），写信给瓦西里，这位巴西琉斯，即君士坦丁堡最后一位皇帝侄女的儿子。他说，两个罗马已经沦陷。然而第三罗马屹立不倒，也绝不会有第四个。他说，没有人能取代你的基督教所多玛。他对瓦西里这样说，
rome to constantinople and now from constantinople to moscow which kind of undergirds i guess you could call it the conceit of the Tsars. And of course, the Tsar... I was about to say the name, the very name. The name itself kind of bears witness. So, you know, the irony is, obviously, the territory of Russia is as far from Rome as you can get in Europe, really. And yet Moscow, probably more than any other european capital you know has has the kind of the bragging rights to the to to be the heir of rome um and this is this is something that is
这就是那种观念，即你拥有某种所谓的“translatio imperii”，即帝国首都的转移，从罗马到君士坦丁堡，现在从君士坦丁堡到莫斯科，这某种程度上支撑了——我想你可以称之为沙皇的自负。当然，沙皇……我正要说出那个名字，那个名字本身。名字本身就证明了这一点。所以，你知道的，具有讽刺意味的是，俄罗斯的领土实际上是欧洲离罗马最远的地方。然而莫斯科，可能比任何其他欧洲首都——你知道的——拥有更有力的吹嘘资本，能够成为罗马的继承者。而且我认为这
i think taken seriously uh and again to kind of touch on the theme of of last week's um special that we did on ukraine we talked about crimea yeah um crimea matters because it is it was it was the seat of classical greek civilization so you have the the city of chersonis um founded by greeks back in the 6th century bc it had been a part of the roman empire under the under you know the heyday of the caesars in the first second centuries a.d and then in the 10th century when vladimir the the prince of kiev who again i think now has to rank as a friend of the show he's been on so many recent episodes he gets baptized that's in chersonisa so the sense of of crimea as the link joining the lands of Muscovy to the north, to the Roman world, is very, very strong.
是我认为被认真对待的事情，再次为了触及我们上周关于乌克兰的特辑的主题，我们谈到了克里米亚，是的，克里米亚之所以重要，是因为它是古典希腊文明的所在地。所以你有克森尼索这座城市——由希腊人在公元前6世纪建立。在公元1世纪至2世纪凯撒的全盛时期，它曾是罗马帝国的一部分。然后在10世纪，基辅公爵弗拉基米尔——我猜他现在也算得上是节目的老朋友了，他在最近好几集里都出场了——他受洗了，就在克森尼索。因此，克里米亚作为连接北方的莫斯科土地与罗马世界的纽带的这种意识，非常、非常强烈。
And the measure of this is that in 1783, under Catherine the Great, as in the great Hussar, Potemkin, her advisor and her lover... Did you have to say that in that kind of gluso accent i mean this has been a very accent free podcast no it's yeah i i couldn't resist it so for temkin for temkin who basically uh supervises the annexation of crimea under under catherine the great he writes to uh to catherine and says to her you have attached the territories which alexander and pompey so alexander the great pompey the great great rival of julius caesar just glanced at to the
这方面的证明是，在1783年，在叶卡捷琳娜大帝的统治下，正如伟大的轻骑兵波将金——她的顾问和她的情人……你非得用那种口音说这个吗？我的意思是，这是一期非常没有口音的播客……不，这，是的，我忍不住。所以波将金，他基本上在叶卡捷琳娜大帝的统治下监督了对克里米亚的吞并，他写信给叶卡捷琳娜说：“你已经将亚历山大和庞培——亚历山大大帝、伟大的庞培（尤利乌斯·恺撒的强劲对手）只是瞥了一眼的领土——并入了俄罗斯的节杖中，并将陶里斯的克森尼索——那是我们基督教的源泉，从而也是我们人性的源泉——现在落入了它的女儿手中。”所以俄罗斯现在通过这些庞培大帝曾统治过的土地与第一罗马联合起来，并通过第二罗马联合起来，因为现在，你知道的，这就是弗拉基米尔受洗的地方，他娶了拜占庭皇帝的女儿。这就是沙皇们认真对待这一点的原因。所以你可以认为，你知道的，或许罗马帝国灭亡的日期，如果有人买账这种沙皇宣传并接受它的话，那将是随着沙皇俄国的处决、也就是终结而告终。
baton of russia and cherson of tarida so that's cherson isis the source of our christianity and thus of our humanity is now in the hands of its daughter so russia is now joined to the first rome in the form of these lands that pompey the great had had ruled and to the second rome because now you know this is where vladimir became was baptized who married the daughter of the byzantine emperor so that is the sense in which the sars do take this seriously yeah so you could argue you know that maybe a date for the end of the Roman Empire, if one buys into this Tsarist propaganda and accepts it, would be with the execution, you know, the termination of Tsarist Russia.
也就是那个恰如其分地被称为罗曼诺夫王朝的皇朝。是的，完全如此。所以是1917年，1918年。没错。所以这很有趣。回到克里米亚，1783年，你提到叶卡捷琳娜大帝吞并了它。所以有趣的是，汤姆，这恰恰是世界上另一端我们那群截然不同的人也开始宣称对罗马遗产拥有主权的时候，也就是美国人。所以美国共和国作为罗马共和国继承人的意识，某种程度上对辛辛那提斯和这些伟大人物的迷恋，但我想你会
Of the aptly named Romanov dynasty. Yes, exactly. So 1917, 1918. Exactly. So that's interesting. And just to go back to the Crimea, so 1783, you said that Catherine the Great absorbs it. So what's interesting about that, Tom, is that that is precisely the moment at which our group of very different people on the other side of the world are also kind of laying claim to Roman heritage, which are the Americans. So the sense of the American Republic being the heir to the Roman Republic, sort of fascination with cincinnatus and with these kind of great characters but i suppose you would
也就是恰如其分的罗曼诺夫王朝。是的，完全正确。所以是1917年，1918年。完全正确。这很有意思。回到克里米亚的话题，你刚才说叶卡捷琳娜大帝在1783年将其吞并。汤姆，有意思的是，正是在那个时刻，地球另一端一群截然不同的人也在某种程度上宣称自己继承了罗马的传统，也就是美国人。因此，美洲共和国被视为罗马共和国的继承者，人们对辛辛纳图斯以及这些伟大人物充满了迷恋，不过我想你会
say well would you that the russia is different from america and indeed from let's say france in that regard because the americans and the french are laying claim to the ideals of rome and to the iconography and stuff but they don't genuinely think they're romans no but the russians i think that is the difference but there are some russ, but they don't genuinely think they're Romans. No. I think that is the difference. But there are some Russians, you're saying, who genuinely think there is an absolutely organic, unbroken continuity and that they are the genuine heirs because of orthodoxy, because of Kievan Rus'
说说看，你觉得俄罗斯在这一点上和美国，以及和比如说法国，有什么不同吗？因为美国人和法国人宣称自己继承了罗马的理想、图腾偶像以及诸如此类的东西，但他们并不真的认为自己是罗马人。没错，但俄罗斯人——我认为这就是区别所在。不过也有一些俄罗斯人，你是说，他们真心地认为有一种绝对有机的、未曾中断的延续性，并且因为正教信仰、因为基辅罗斯
and all that history, that they are the heirs to, that they are Romans. They're not the heirs to Rome. That's the wrong way of putting it, that they are the Romans. I mean, it has a quality of paradox, because you look at Washington with all its, you know, the Capitol and the Senate and its Roman architecture, and you say, well, of course, it's much more Roman city. But it isn't, because it doesn't have that sense of itself as being literally descended from Rome, as having a kind of supernatural degree of continuity,
以及所有这些历史，他们就是正统的继承人，他们就是罗马人。他们不是罗马的继承人。这种说法不对，应该说他们就是罗马人。我的意思是，这带有一种悖论的性质，因为你看华盛顿，到处都是它的国会大厦、参议院和罗马式建筑，你会说，好吧，这当然是一座更具罗马风格的城市。但事实并非如此，因为它没有那种认为自己是罗马的直系后代、拥有一种超自然程度的延续性的自我认知，
which I think how seriously people have taken it over the course of history could be debated. But I think it does hang in the air as something that can be invoked at certain stages. And perhaps the most fascinating witness for that is not actually with the Romanovs, but with Stalin. Because there are enduring stories, and I think that they are mythical, but the very fact that they exist is in itself telling. That when the Nazis reached the outer limits of Moscow, Stalin, who of course is a committed atheist, profoundly anti-clerical, takes the most sacred icon and he puts it in a plane. It's an icon of the Virgin. and the plane then circles around the city limits of uh moscow
虽然我认为历史上人们对这种认知的认真程度还有待讨论。但我认为它确实悬在空中，作为一种在特定阶段可以被唤起的象征。也许这方面最迷人的见证其实不在罗曼诺夫王朝，而是在斯大林身上。因为有一些经久不衰的故事——我认为它们是神话，但它们的存在本身就说明了问题。当纳粹抵达莫斯科的外围时，斯大林——他当然是一个坚定的无神论者，极其反教权——把最神圣的圣像放进了一架飞机里。那是一尊圣母圣像。然后这架飞机在莫斯科市的外围盘旋
and in doing that they're echoing what the byzantines did when they were besieged by pagan enemies that they would take the icon of the virgin and carry it around the city walls and it was said that the virgin herself would appear which in turn is an echo of stories told by athenians that the the virgin the virgin goddess Athena would walk around the walls of Athens. So there is a kind of, you know, it's a very, very distant sense of continuity, but a very, very faint sense. And I would say that there are people around Putin who do seem to be taking this seriously. So in 2008, there was the head of a monastery in Moscow who was the spiritual advisor to Putin's then wife, directed a film for Russian television that was about the fall of of constantinople um and the the blame for the fall of constantinople was laid less on the turks than on the crusaders who um this the head of this monastery father ticon shevkunov says that they are crude ignorant primitive whose chief occupation
这样做，他们是在呼应拜占庭人在被异教徒敌人围困时所做的事情，当时他们会带着圣母的圣像绕着城墙行走，据说圣母本人会显灵，这反过来又呼应了雅典人流传的故事，即处女女神雅典娜会在雅典城墙周围行走。所以这是一种，你知道的，非常非常遥远的延续感，但也是一种非常非常微弱的感觉。而且我认为普京身边确实有一些人似乎在认真对待这件事。所以在2008年，莫斯科一家修道院的院长——他当时是普京妻子的精神顾问——为俄罗斯电视台导演了一部关于君士坦丁堡陷落的电影，
was sacking and pillaging and that is um very much but know, it's a commentary on American fund managers and asset strippers and all those kinds of people. So it's casting, again, Moscow as Constantinople and, yeah, as kind of Western capitalists, as the Crusaders. And the Russian foreign minister in 2016, when, of course, Putin ordered the annexation of Crimea from Ukraine, I mean, he, you know, as Putin has been doing, he gives this history lesson. And he says that Russ was the successor to the Byzantine Empire. You know, he's saying this.
而君士坦丁堡陷落的责任与其说是归咎于土耳其人，不如说是归咎于十字军，这位修道院院长吉洪·谢夫库诺夫神父说他们是粗俗、无知、原始的人，其主要职业
So this is, you know, it's Lavrov, isn't it? Yeah, Sergei Lavrov. I mean, you've written about this, haven't you? I'm reading your essay here. Rus bent under, but was not broken by the heavy Mongolian yoke
就是劫掠和破坏，这在很大程度上是……你知道的，这是对美国基金经理和资产剥离者以及所有这类人的评论。所以这再次将莫斯科塑造为君士坦丁堡，而将西方资本主义者塑造为十字军。而在2016年，当普京下令从乌克兰吞并克里米亚时，俄罗斯外长——我的意思是，正如普京一直在做的那样，他上了一堂历史课。他说罗斯是拜占庭帝国的继承人。你看，他是这么说的。
and managed to emerge from this dire trial as a single state, which was later regarded by both the West and the East as the successor to the Byzantine Empire that ceased to exist in 1453.
所以这就是拉夫罗夫，对吧？是的，谢尔盖·拉夫罗夫。我的意思是，你写过关于这个的文章，不是吗？我正在读你写的文章：“罗斯在沉重的蒙古铁蹄下屈服，但没有被摧毁，并在这一可怕的考验中成功崛起为一个单一国家，后来被西方和东方视为于1453年消亡的拜占庭帝国的继承人。”
I mean, Tom, Liz Truss doesn't write essays like this. No, no. And, you know, there were famous images when the Russian jets were taking off with the annexation of Crimea of priests casting it, you know, blessing them, putting holy water on it and so on, as priests would have done in Byzantium.
我是说，汤姆，莉兹·特拉斯可写不出这样的文章。不，不。而且，你知道，当俄罗斯喷气式飞机伴随着克里米亚的并然而起飞时，有这样著名的画面：神父们向飞机洒圣水、祝福它们，就像拜占庭的神父们过去所做的那样。
And the parallel was very deliberate. It was kind of very conscious. So I think that, you know, it is, you know, we call this episode undead Rome, kind of zombie Rome. But I mean, there's a kind of sense in which it's not entirely dead. And I thought also the other, so that's one way in which I think this kind of the ghost of Rome haunts geopolitics, even into the 21st century. And the other one, which was very, very striking while it was around, was the use that the Islamic State put the Roman Empire to
这种平行是非常刻意的。这是一种非常自觉的行为。所以我认为，你知道的，我们把这一集叫做“死而不僵的罗马”，也就是某种僵尸罗马。但我的意思是，在某种程度上，它并没有完全死去。我也觉得另一件事——所以这是罗马的幽灵甚至在21世纪仍在纠缠地缘政治的一种方式。而另一种方式，在它存在的时候非常非常显眼，那就是伊斯兰国对罗马帝国的利用，
when it was kind of going strong. Because we talked about how for Muslims, the idea of Rome is very important because you have these hadiths, these sayings attributed to Muhammad in which it's said that Islam will conquer first Constantinople and then Rome, which therefore means that Rome must still be going. That's the kind of the logic. And the hadith that the Islamic State picked on was that the last hour will not come until the Romans landed Al-Amakh or in Dabiq. And Dabiq is a small town in northern Syria. And they called their propaganda magazine Dabiq. So they put it out every kind of month, I think.
当它正处于全盛时期的时候。因为我们讨论过，对于穆斯林来说，罗马的概念非常重要，因为有这些圣训，也就是归属于穆罕默德的言论，其中说伊斯兰教将首先征服君士坦丁堡，然后征服罗马，因此这意味着罗马必须依然存在。这就是其中的逻辑。而伊斯兰国挑中的圣训是：直到罗马人在阿马克或达比克登陆之前，末日不会来临。而达比克是叙利亚北部的一个小镇。他们把他们的宣传杂志命名为达比克。所以我认为他们每个月左右都会出版一次。
And one of those editions had on the front of it the great obelisk that Caligula had brought to Rome that then got put up in the centre of St. Peter's Square in the Vatican. And they showed this with the Islamic state flag flying from it. And they had this kind of editorial where they said, we will conquer your Rome, break your crosses, enslave your women by the permission of Allah the Exalted. This is his promise to us. He is glorified and he does not fail in his promise if we do not reach that time then our children and grandchildren will reach it and they will sell your sons as slaves at the slave market oh my god so this was um you know resuscitating this sense of the west as a roman empire and using it as a kind of motivation and it's it's not just you, this is not a perspective that's confined
其中一期杂志的封面是卡利古拉带到罗马、后来被竖立在梵蒂冈圣彼得广场中心的大方尖碑。他们展示了这个画面，上面飘扬着伊斯兰国的旗帜。他们发表了一篇社论，其中说道：“我们将在至高真主的允许下征服你们的罗马，打破你们的十字架，奴役你们的妇女。这是他对我们的承诺。他是受赞颂的，他不会违背他的承诺。如果我们没有赶上那个时代，那么我们的子孙后代将会赶上，他们将在奴隶市场上把你们的儿子当作奴隶卖掉。”天哪！所以这真是……你知道的，重新唤醒了西方作为罗马帝国的这种感觉，并将其用作一种动力，而且不仅仅是你，这并不是局限于
just to the ideologues of Islamic State, who are obviously the most brutal and unpleasant of the lot. But there's also Yusuf al-Karadawi, who's a very, very significant Muslim scholar. He was chairman of the International Union of Muslim Scholars. He was a trustee of the Oxford Centre
伊斯兰国的思想家们的观点，他们显然是其中最残暴、最令人讨厌的一群人。但也包括优素福·卡拉达维，他是一位非常非常重要的穆斯林学者。他是国际穆斯林学者联合会的主席。他是牛津大学伊斯兰研究中心的理事
for Islamic Studies. And he took this hadith that Islam will conquer Constantinople and then Rome. And he says that Islam will come to Rome as a conqueror and a victor. And he's taking this very, very seriously. And Rome there means what, Tom? Literally Rome. It literally means Rome. So there was, and you can see this from what an imam at one of the defense academies in Saudi Arabia said.
他采纳了“伊斯兰教将征服君士坦丁堡然后征服罗马”的圣训。他说伊斯兰教将作为征服者和胜利者来到罗马。他非常非常认真地对待这一点。汤姆，那里的罗马指的是什么？字面意义上的罗马。它字面意思就是罗马。所以，从沙特阿拉伯某防务学院的一位伊玛目所说的话中，你可以看出这一点。
Again, he's talking about this hadith. He says, we will control the land of the Vatican. We will control Rome and we will introduce Islam to it. So weirdly, the Roman Empire's greatest enemy, enemy the caliphate kind of keeps the ghost alive so i was going to say you know rome there is doing the fulfilling the function of babylon and we talked about babylon and yes absolutely but it but it isn't it isn't because when we talk about babylon now when i don't know when rastafarians talk about babylon i mean they're not literally talking about yeah you're right babylon yeah This has a different dimension, doesn't it? Which is, you're right,
同样，他谈到了这个圣训。他说：“我们将控制梵蒂冈的土地，我们将控制罗马，并将伊斯兰教引入其中。”所以奇怪的是，罗马帝国的最大敌人——哈里发国，某种程度上让这个幽灵活了下来。所以我本想说，你知道，那里的罗马正在履行巴比伦的功能，我们讨论过巴比伦，是的，绝对是的。但它又不是，因为它不是——当我们现在谈论巴比伦时，当——我不知道，当拉斯塔法里教徒谈论巴比伦时，我的意思是他们并不是在字面意义上谈论——是的，你是对的，巴比伦，是的。这有着不同的维度，不是吗？也就是说，你是对的，
it is the same dimension of its luxury, its wealth, its wickedness and corruption. But they also literally mean the city in Italy. It has a geopolitical dimension as well. Yes, they literally mean the city. And they literally mean that, you know, for the Islamic State, the United States and its allies are Rome and they're also crusaders.
它具有与其奢侈、财富、邪恶和腐败相同的维度。但他们也是字面意义上指意大利的那座城市。它也具有地缘政治的维度。是的，他们字面意思就是指这座城。他们的意思是，对伊斯兰国来说，美国及其盟友就是罗马，他们也是十字军。
And there's a sense in which these various enemies from Islam's history are still kind of roaming around like the undead. Yeah. Roaming around, Tom. Very good. Roaming, roaming around. Very good. It's always good to get a pun in. Before we finish, there's one last, perhaps, heir to the Roman Empire, which I think is an unexpected one, but quite a fun one. Go on, go on. And this is to go back to the Roman Empire in the West. So the question is, and I'm sure you'll have the answer to this. What is the last territory of the Roman Empire in the West where people feel that they are Roman to succumb to barbarian invaders? Oh, my word, Tom.
在某种意义上，伊斯兰教历史上的这些各种敌人仍然像行尸走肉一样四处游荡。是的。四处游荡，汤姆。非常好。游荡，四处游荡。非常好。能用上一个双关语总是好的。在我们结束之前，还有最后一个也许是罗马帝国的继承人，我认为这是一个意料之外的继承人，但也相当有趣。说下去，说下去。这就是回到西方的罗马帝国。所以问题是，我确信你会有答案。在西方，罗马帝国的最后一个领土是什么？那里的人们觉得自己是罗马人，最终向野蛮人入侵者屈服？哦，天哪，汤姆。
I'm going to say it is Sicily. No, you see, I think there's a very strong case for saying it's northern Wales. There speaks a man who's never been to Wales so Britain notoriously is the first province in the west to slip Roman imperial control yeah but um it's clear that there are people in Roman Britain who continue to feel that they are roman and um among these are various princes who claim descent from um an authentic roman figure called magnus maximus so he's the most he's a modest name in yes what's his name mean the great the greatest great the greatest great the greatest i think i might that's donald trump's name surely yes i know at least he hasn't picked up on that um so he yeah so he's a
我要说是西不勒斯。不，你看，我认为有一个非常充分的理由说明它是北威尔士。说这话的人显然从来没去过威尔士。众所周知，不列颠是西方第一个摆脱罗马帝国控制的省份。是的，但很明显，罗马不列颠有一些人继续觉得自己是罗马人，在这些人当中有各种各样的王子，他们自称是某个名叫马格西姆斯（Magnus Maximus）的真实罗马人物的后代。所以他是一个温和的名字——是的，他的名字是什么意思？伟大，最伟大，最伟大，最伟大，最伟大。我想这大概就是唐纳德·特朗普的名字吧？是的，我知道，至少他没有注意到这一点。所以他——是的，所以他是一个
usurper who gathers together all the um all the various kind of uh legions and and and reserving uh remaining garrisons and takes them to the continent where he briefly flourishes as a would-be emperor and then gets killed and that essentially is the end of Roman centralized power in Britain but what he's done is that he has endowed various kind of chiefs, big men with imperial authority. So in that sense, all these guys are endowed with their Roman office holders. And over the course of the centuries that follow, these lines of princes preserve a sense of themselves as licensed you know as as licensed by by rome as roman officials and as descendants of of magnus um maximus whom they come to call max and gledig and max and gledig
篡位者，他召集了所有的——所有的各种军团和剩余的卫戍部队，把他们带到了欧洲大陆，在那里他作为一名准皇帝短暂地显赫了一阵，然后被杀害了。这基本上就是不列颠罗马中央权力的终结。但他所做的是，他赋予了各种酋长、大人物以帝国的权威。因此从这个意义上说，所有这些人都被赋予了罗马官员的身份。在随后的几个世纪里，这些王子血脉保持了一种自我意识，认为自己是得到授权的——你知道的，是得到罗马授权的罗马官员，是马格西姆斯的后代，他们后来称之为马克森·格莱迪格（Macsen Wledig），而马克森·格莱迪格
is and i apologize to any welsh listeners my welsh welsh yeah max and gledig uh and he is the founder of the lines of all these various welsh princes right And he appears in the Mabinogion. He's a kind of big figure to play with. He's the kind of ancestral head of all these various princes who, in the long run, Edward I will terminate. So Edward I is a hammer not just of the Scots, but of the Romans. So you could say that Edward I is the kind of the last barbarian conqueror to subdue a region of the Western Empire that still feels itself to be Roman. But there's a further twist. There's a further twist.
是——如果有什么威尔士听众的话我表示抱歉，我的威尔士语——马克森·格莱迪格，他是所有这些威尔士王子血脉的创立者，对吧？他出现在《马比诺吉昂》（Mabinogion）中。他是一个可以大做文章的重要人物。他是所有这些不同王子的始祖，从长远来看，爱德华一世将终结他们。所以爱德华一世不仅是苏格兰人的锤子，也是罗马人的锤子。所以你可以说爱德华一世是那种征服了西方帝国一个依然觉得自己是罗马人的地区的最后一个野蛮人征服者。但还有一个转折。还有一个转折。
So in 1301, what does Edward I do with his son? Make some Prince of Wales, Tom. Even I know that. Prince of Walesales because the welsh supposedly have said we want a prince and so edward makes his son prince of wales to restore the line that had been broken that's line of descent from max and gledig magnus maximus latter days of roman britain and to say it is revived so the prince of wales in that sense is the heir to the roman empire in the west meaning you could argue yeah that the law the last person in public life
所以在1301年，爱德华一世对他的儿子做了什么？立他为威尔士亲王，汤姆。连我都懂这个。威尔士亲王，因为威尔士人据称说过“我们需要一个亲王”，所以爱德华让他的儿子担任威尔士亲王，以恢复那个曾经断裂的血脉，也就是从马克森·格莱迪格、马格西姆斯以及罗马不列颠末期传承下来的血脉，并宣称它已经复苏。从这个意义上说，威尔士亲王就是西方罗马帝国的继承人。这意味着你可以争辩说，是的，公共生活中最后一个
with a line of descent from the roman empire is none other than charles prince prince charles prince of wales The last Roman. Oh, that bombshell. Well, Tom, I think that is an absolutely ridiculous argument. So when I think of people dining on stuffed thrushes on golden plates, watching gladiatorial games, I don't think of the people of Barmouth or i mean are people in i don't know i'm trying to think of welsh places are people in landudno in the 12th century calling themselves romans and surely they're not welsh listeners please address your remarks to tom holland and
拥有罗马帝国血脉的人正是查尔斯王子——威尔士亲王查尔斯。最后一个罗马人。噢，这个重磅炸弹。好吧，汤姆，我认为这是一个极其荒谬的论点。所以，当我想象人们在金盘子上大嚼塞满料的鸫鸟、观看角斗士比赛时，我想到的可不是巴茅斯（Barmouth）的人，或者说——我是说，威尔士人有没有——我正在努力想威尔士的地名——12世纪兰迪德诺（Llandudno）的人会自称是罗马人吗？他们当然不会。威尔士的听众们，请向汤姆·霍兰发表你们的意见，并
tell him whether or not you feel roman prince charles if you're listening do likewise well prince william as well yeah. Yeah, of course. Yeah. Of course. Maybe they should have a sort of – well, of course, you're great pals with Prince William, Tom. Yeah. You met him at that charity, do you? Both Aston Villa supporters, like David Cameron.
告诉他你们到底有没有觉得自己是罗马人。查尔斯王子，如果你在听的话，也请这么做。好吧，还有威廉王子，是的。是的，当然。是的。当然。也许他们应该举行某种——好吧，当然，你和威廉王子是好哥们儿，汤姆。是的。你在那个慈善活动上见过他，对吧？你们都是阿斯顿维拉的球迷，就像大卫·卡梅伦一样。
And maybe you should recommend that they have a kind of Roman investiture ceremony rather than – But I think it's exciting that maybe the two figures with claims to be Roman are Vladimir Putin and Prince Charles. Two very different... The Emperor of the East, the Emperor of the West. Right. Maybe they should just carve up the world between them. I wouldn't put too much money on Prince Charles in that kind of mano a mano.
也许你应该建议他们举行某种罗马式的授职仪式，而不是——但我认为这很令人兴奋，也许那两个有资格被称为罗马人的人是弗拉基米尔·普京和查尔斯王子。两个截然不同的人……东方的皇帝，西方的皇帝。对。也许他们应该直接在他们之间瓜分世界。在这场肉搏战中，我不会把太多的赌注押在查尔斯王子身上。
No. I wouldn't send him into the conference chamber. No. Right. On that bombshell, as you rightly said um i think we've completely you know it took edward gibbon 20 years but it's taken us two hours two less than two hours uh and edward gibbon did not end on a welsh note which i think is greatly discredit so we've got all kinds of treats coming up um the assassination of jfk um can't remember what. Lethal fashion. Lethal fashion, killer fashion,
不。我不会把他送进会议室。不。好了，伴随着这个重磅炸弹，正如你刚才所说，我想我们已经完全——你知道的，爱德华·吉本花了他20年时间，而我们只花了两个小时不到的时间，而且爱德华·吉本可没有以威尔士作结，我认为这大大降低了他的可信度。所以我们接下来还有各种各样的精彩内容：肯尼迪遇刺案……记不清是什么了。致命时尚。致命时尚，杀手时尚，
and fashion. Oil. Stuff about energy union. Yeah. Yeah. Lots of stuff. Loads of stuff. So thank you very much for listening
还有时尚。石油。关于能源联盟的东西。是的。是的。很多内容。超级多。所以非常感谢大家的收听，
and we will see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishtertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下期再见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家番外、提前解锁节目、免广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishtertainment.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。